ce n'est pas vraiment une surprise et le
bruit courait depuis plusieurs jours
face à une nouvelle vague de l'épidémie
le gouvernement nous reconfirmons pour
un mois minimum comme en mars dernier
enfin non pas tout à fait c'est bien un
nouveau confinement mais différent cette
fois plusieurs secteurs d'activité ont
été laissés ouverts les services publics
notamment et le btp secteur essentiel au
premier semestre la moitié de l'écart de
pib constatée avec l'allemagne
s'expliquer par l'écart de production
dans la construction va donc falloir
continuer d'aller au boulot casque sur
la tête
masque sur nos visages et attestations
bien en main en revanche pour tous les
commerces non essentiels c'est un peu le
coup de grâce les magasins non
alimentaires les cafés les cinémas les
coiffeurs les salles de spectacles et
autres resteront fermés avec deux choses
une promesse d' emmanuel macron de
réévaluer la situation d'ici quinze
jours c'est la propagation du virus
baisse et une nouvelle aide de 10000
euros maximum du fonds de solidarité et
pour couvrir leurs frais fixes
en plus du chômage partiel maintenu en
tout c'est une rallonge de 20 milliards
d'euros que jean castex a annoncé devant
l'assemblée nationale jeudi
au delà du report des échéances fiscales
c'est celui du remboursement des prêts
garantis par l'état lancé depuis la
première vague qui est reportée à 2022
enfin drc annoncé un crédit d'impôt pour
les bailleurs qui renonce à un mois de
loyer sur la période octobre novembre
décembre
malgré toutes les mesures la france a vu
son nombre de pauvres augmenté de 1
million après le premier confinement
qu'en sera-t-il après le second